Hier wird die Zukunft des Schweizer Käses
neu gestaltet.
Aus der Nähe von Bern
kommen vegane Versionen
von Fondue und Co.,
und das alles ohne Milch.
Die Basis bilden Cashewkerne.
Die Firma „New Roots“ in Oberdiessbach
produziert jeden Monat rund 150.000 Stück
veganer Käsealternativen.
Ich denke eigentlich, dass es die Zukunft ist,
weil es einfach …
wir müssen uns umorientieren.
Das ist einfach die Evolution des Menschen.
2015 gründet Freddy Hunziker
sein eigenes Unternehmen,
mit gerade 21 Jahren.
Käse darf er seine Camemberts und
acht weitere vegane Sorten nicht nennen,
weil sie keine Tiermilch enthalten.
Die Schweizer Käsekunst kommt
aber auch hier zum Einsatz.
Wir haben hier unsere
Camembert-Alternative,
die aus Cashewkernen hergestellt ist,
aus der Cashew-Milch.
Dann werden sie hier über
zwei bis drei Wochen eingelagert.
Abwechslung vom Alltag und Erholung sucht
Freddy Hunziker in den Bergen nebenan.
Sein Leben verändert sich 2015 schlagartig.
Er will Profibiker werden,
doch ein Unfall zerstört seine Karrierepläne.
In dieser Zeit setzt er sich mit Regeneration
und veganer Ernährung auseinander
und entwickelt seine Gründeridee.
Durch den Sport wurde ich
sicherlich ziemlich diszipliniert –
auch durch das ganze Training
und die ganze Herausforderung,
an einem solchen Wettkampf
auch teilzunehmen,
und das hat mir eigentlich sicher
einen guten Lebensweg gezeigt,
für das Unternehmertum ready zu sein.
Aus seiner Idee ist ein Unternehmen
mit 25 Mitarbeitern geworden.
Wichtig ist dem Team, dass Cashewkerne
weniger CO2 als Milchprodukte erzeugen –
auch wenn sie aus Übersee kommen.
Die Herstellungsart eines Rohstoffes
ist eigentlich eines der wichtigsten Teile
in puncto CO2-Bilanz.
Unsere Cashewkerne wachsen
auf nährreichen Böden,
ohne dass Wasser dazugesetzt werden muss.
Das einzige Negative ist dann
eigentlich der ganze Transport,
der rund jetzt in puncto CO2-Bilanz
fünf Prozent dazuzählt.
Das ist eigentlich ein sehr kleiner Bruchteil.
Auch in anderen Teilen des Landes wird die
traditionelle Käsekunst auf den Kopf gestellt.
In Genf,
im französischsprachigen Teil der Schweiz,
eröffnet 2017 die „Crémerie Végane“ –
einer der ersten Läden in der Metropole,
die vegane Alternativen
zu Milchprodukten anbietet.
Cashewkerne bilden auch hier die Basis.
In dem kleinen Familienunternehmen werden
in Handarbeit neun Sorten hergestellt,
darunter veganen Alternativen von Klassikern
wie Ziegenkäseröllchen, Camembert
und Gruyère-Hartkäse.
2,6 Prozent der Schweizer sind Veganer,
doch nicht nur sie suchen den Laden auf.
Immer mehr Menschen vertragen
Milchprodukte nicht.
Vor allem haben wir
Flexitarier und „Allesesser“,
die zwar etwas verändern wollen,
die etwas besser machen wollen,
die aber noch nicht bereit sind,
den ganz großen Schritt zu wagen.
Zurück in Oberdiessbach im Berner Mittelland
im deutschsprachigen Teil der Schweiz.
Können die Schweizer vom Geschmack her
veganen von normalem Käse aus Milch
unterscheiden?
Sehr erfrischend,
Kräuter, also geschmacksintensiv,
aber man merkt, dass es nicht Käse ist.
Leichter Käsegeschmack,
bisschen Kräuter,
und dann hört‘s auf.
Um noch mehr zu überzeugen,
arbeiten Freddy Hunziker und sein Team
an der veganen Variante des Schweizer
Schmelzkäsekults, dem Fondue.
Für uns war ein Fondue
von großer Wichtigkeit,
weil eigentlich ein Schweizer ...
traditionelles Schweizer Fondue verkörpert,
wofür die Schweizer Tradition und
das Käsereihandwerk einsteht.
Ein Ziel der alternativen Käsehersteller ist es,
auch Nicht-Veganer anzusprechen,
um eine ethischere, gesündere
und nachhaltigere Möglichkeit
als Kuhmilch aufzuzeigen.
Vielleicht ein Käse der Zukunft –
nicht nur im Alpenland Schweiz.